Good morning
wolfram 鯱 a
Jerumi um wolfram car Tokyo 2 types Well my
sister Nakamura
Thank you for participating in that wolfram Acharu conference japan 2015 Thank you very much for joining us
today.  I
would like to explain a little about the virtual conference
. At the
head office,
in addition to physical on-site seminars,
we have been actively
disclosing information to that
predecessor Kaniza through online training and virtual conferences.  It was a lesson for the past few years that I dispatched that explanation staff from the office to
physically explain how to use Matemachika and that function, but
in Okinawa City, that Japan for Japan.
Virtual conferences customized for user 6 of Japan
have time lag and
language problems. Unfortunately,
until now, full-scale implementation
has been postponed, but last year
wolfram cloud programming
Karasuran wolfram plastic
programming.  In
Japan, which has the second largest number of users after the North American continent, when Mercer-less networks such as the cloud and
Matemachika Online release other products, it seems that we should be more proactive in disclosing that information at virtual conferences and
the like.  Contribution has
increased even in the head office, and it was held today.
Well, thanks to everyone's passionate support, well, the head office
is already a
us centric company
, but for that kind of Japanese user.
I
came up with the idea of actively disclosing that information, so w
e are holding virtual conferences in various ways, but we ar
relaying that server in the United State
.  Well, there are still technical problems such as time lag, and so on. This time, well, I
've done
various demonstrations and experiments, and
this time, that web page like that
page.  Wouldn't it be nice to have informed
you?  It's not written on the eb page, isn't it
? It's not that real time is far away, but
I decided to use a method in which the talks that experts in each field of the head office
went to live in advance are shown in
Japanese
as a webcast.
Instead, the staff of that resentful Asia, including the skewer,
is participating online,
and even during the acquisition, if you
ask a question or comment by chatting,
we
will be waiting for you to respond in real time.
Please use it by all means.
Aiming to be like a virtual conference and that
online seminar.
We also competed with the head office
to deepen those technical problems and make the content
understandable if it becomes that content Miyama.  I
'm using only the information about my father over there and the information about that
little one over there. It's like using Japanese information and changing to the content that I used.
I'll do my best from now on, so please look forward to it.
8 I think it's a little later in South Africa There
is a little notice and
it is possible to download from that presented tab, so
it's a back screen, but
if possible, make it full screen
I think that the contents of the video
will be very thin, so I think that the chat lounge
will be inaccessible at the moment so that I can enter after the end of the previous talk and become a kneading gar
.  I think that I would like you to ice it
. Then, I would like to
briefly introduce that today's
presentation
. It's from this 10 minutes
, but first of all, machine learning
8 Machine learning with machine learning.
Well, before that, the 8 functions of data mining Japan have
9 points in the east, so
I will take that special attack on it. And the geographic information is
various Chilean art
Well, it is on the Internet.
It's like a google map.
You can access such geographic information and
use it to include various contents and visualizations
. For example, the distance between the two points.
Well, that love is a diaper, so it's a distance
, so I'll give a presentation that includes that application, such as the display of an immediate appearance that connects between them
. Then, the time
series is that,
for example, that science and engineering system.  The time series can be treated as almost continuous data now,
like the data coming out of the sensor,
for example, what kind
of 8 tablets
are
sick, but
that,
for example, sociological science.
There are cases where such data is missing on that day, on a daily basis, on a weekly basis, or in between.
Well, to analyze such data, treat
it a little
differently from that continuous data.
Well,
I have to prepare various flowers about it. I've prepared that. I'll show you
how it's actually used and how it's actually used
in the data
.
Then 8 10:45  That introduction from the minute,
or the online
, is finally there. If you wait,
that's how
Matemachika is released. That was released last year.
I've been trying to put that cdf
that player
as a web browser plug-in on a tablet-type pc with such a hole, such as ipad
, but it's
quite
technical.  There are so many problems
that it's big and I haven't solved it neatly yet.
Instead, that web
browser Nowadays, it's normal to use various applications with that web browser
as an
interface
only for that pc.  Well, it's the same with
tablets, and for example, in the
embedded world,
that method is becoming mainstream, so wait and use that
Matemachika as that web lag web application like a line that gets involved
.  If
you ask, it is online that you have made such a direction that
way. The user behind the hut  I think that there are a lot of people
, so I hope you can
see it including those who are 8 well,
and the
wolfram data science
platform is the data size in the cloud, for example, big
data, that data.  I hope you can see that in the 8
presentations,
but
how do you capture that data
, analyze it, visualize it
, and share the results with that flower person?
In the workflow,
I made 8 presentations on how to use the wintering data and
how to use it. And finally, I would like to
introduce you to Ra in that system. This
is that system.  Although it was the absolute English version up to the front line
, I proceeded to Japaneseize it in version 4
8 It is not completely yet, but it is a
major
menu etc. Most of that document
is translated into Japanese  Then,
how to actually
model and simulate that Japaneseized system
using Teller is what Maruyama et al.
Do all that operation on Tokyo day.  I've done 8
videos, so
I hope you can see it. If you have
any questions, Maruyama, who is touching that reality most
, has a chat room with that art.
If you have any questions, he will answer that directly,
so
thank you very much. Well then
, I think it's about time for that child, so the
first session First machine learning Then
that first that geographic information and machine  Learning
, calculation of geographic information, and time series are so-so
Matematica, which was
taken from the hospitalization blowing
, but
I would like to see a video about it.